hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to don't starve we
survived the night Brokeback Mountain
style never mind that's not uh uh uh I
thought we work in a talk about his
wheels cold we had to turn the turn we
didn't even have a 10 get Oh get in the
tent all right anyway I'm gonna restart
that cuz that's awful
oh hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to don't starve with
Bob say hi Bob hello hELCO welcome we're
doing great
everything is perfect and we're awesome
at video games as Evers oh yes
I blame Wade as usual I just like to
start this episode by saying I blame
Wade okay so what we need to do now is
we need to still find the gold thing Hey
look look piggy piggy piggy piggy piggy
piggy
Oh ease he's messing with me guys oh
he's intentionally messing with the guys
dude look at the Smackdown this guy's oh
go go get a pig I don't think he's doing
too well
and we like can we like feel his stuff
uh I don't think it has any stomach grab
the seat well there's a rock over here
he's distract them
yeah good job big guy up where's my
pickaxe the pig just died I got one the
pig just wait to fall golden there's a
mine yeah yeah get it oh get in it do it
I will protect you or whatever okay get
that gold if you can damn it we need Oh
exceeds carry capacity we got a grenade
hang on hang on what we need to do is we
need to build a chest and to build a
chest I need to refine wood so I'm gonna
find you a massage machine should I
don't add that battle yes you should
build it actually that's actually built
the science machine
you know I displace it here though we
don't want this to be our area hang on
I'm gonna go back we had to cooperate
corroborate whatever I you know I can't
say words I'm a crazy old lady Han so I
need we're crazy always just looking at
it Oh bill died okay I'm making logs
into boards and the board will be made
into a chest and then with the chest
I'll be able to get okay with the chest
I'll be able to will will will be able I
god dammit I can't say words today
well what do you know all these recipes
I feel left out because I am an old lady
and I'm very smart and I know a lot of
things I was a librarian I'm gonna dig
this grave librarian a librarian
there's too much barium here I'll dig it
for you old lady I already got a no no
it's already done I brought my sanity
whatever whatever let's go back to let's
go back home so that we can address this
issue properly wait wait wait
I have to pick up hardened rubber bung I
know I dug it out of the grave cuz
someone buried themself with it for some
day eysan is that not worth having I'd
have no idea you know there's a lot of
items on that I'm gonna pass yeah
there's a lot of items in here that I
figure are junk but you never know they
might actually be snowgo you want off
the universe no you can't
I've tried mate okay that's good cuz I
was gonna so oh good yes please yes
where'd our friars go
so are we trying to go back to where a
fire were the place where all the golden
spiders were no no goo goo goo no oh we
should build a base right here so that
we can have a place to attack them when
the time comes
yeah yeah sounds good I know okay so I'm
gonna build the chest you're like oh
it's a science machine here yes we
should totally where should I put it
like I'm building the sturdy container
right there yes I'll put the science
machine right near that yes exactly
perfect that way that way that way that
way yeah science machine wow that was
surprisingly easy
yeah there's no crafting timer there's
like instant Danny's you plop it on the
ground there it is whoo I can make a
backpack yes yes yay oh we got the
backpack that's yes
why do you know more about this game
than I do I am the greatest well that's
history let's let's not go crazy I'm
gonna make it telltale ow well then I
made a telltale heart but I can't bring
a ghost back to life oh why did it sound
like you got punched in the face I did
you tense in the face
it sucked my blood I'm gonna buy that in
the chest so that we have type of shovel
now all right I could have made you a
shovel and an opulent pickaxe that
sounds fun I don't know what an opulent
pickaxe
prototypes of shovel right pitchfork
what's a razor 400 shaving in case of
robot grow robot beard I can shave my
Robo beard how many rocks do you have at
which one is rocks 6 6 rocks poop we
can't make a bigger campfire so we got
to stick with poop I kill I've been
making a fire pit please oh you can make
it fun we quicky make environment
moosh like what like such ly and thusly
with the fire pit I don't how did you do
that uh I a fire pit takes two logs and
twelve stones I must have had two stacks
of rocks yeah you like maybe I'm a dummy
yeah when we do this we're gonna have to
have understand confidence each other if
we're gonna survive this adventure well
I have to say I have okay eyesight but I
cannot swim
quit dream on sir run away hold on
you're kidding me no no is it why do I
don't know no no no no no no no wait
wait I have an idea yeah burn it
oh yeah why are you so good at this game
burn how are you how do you even know
this stuff is he gonna light all of our
things on but I might just do that
oh that why aren't you dying Oh every
oak oh god I can't go near him because
he lights me on fire fire haha well
let's lead them away from the forest
okay and he's out of fire this is not
going well
Oh God you deserve titles like a
mannequin in the butt hey whoa whoa iwo
jima light him on fire coming after me
well don't I can't I gotta I gotta hit
him I got him oh I can't huh that has to
damage him it's a possible way that does
not do it maybe it would be easier if we
were hitting him - he's a tree monster
okay hey I'll kite him you hit him I'm
hitting him good oh okay okay okay I
gotta be a ghost again okay oh I'm gonna
be a ghost again no no I got it we're
gonna get it are we doing anything at
all to him I've no I'd really dark I
always post it Oh
no no okay hey ha ha ha wait what he
doesn't know what to do he's so confused
oh no no he got me oh it's okay he
doesn't get along
ha ha ha Barry had some intense combat
music to this okay yeah it's like we
take turns and then he turns all right
oh yeah you spider get out of here
you're ruining our plans
oh wait I'm gonna die again
god damn it spider cut kite the
spider this way yeah yeah oh no oh no oh
no I know our camera I was going
terribly wrong why did we camp here
I don't know why was there a dream
officer right by us
Oh kill kill initial okay he's almost
idealistic like a legaly guy just a lot
of a good God don't you try to leave
that dog oh god yeah I got him Oh 101
final exam okay okay okay that's not
monster meat I didn't want you I am
being poisoned wanna do that okay
bye-bye
there's a heart in the chest why is
there another spider this is going
wonderfully
so shop it's fine no okay it's days
everything better now hide it well how
do we get rid of cream oh no
come here you bastard
okay yes yes yes yes yes yes okay dad
good good I'll take the soap put it in
the chest go back to hiding the tree
monster back and forth okay we're gonna
get this guy eventually I'm gonna store
this in this nice to be invincible no no
no no no no so we'll just do the back
and forth the back and back and forth
see oh okay
well somebody kidding me ah I'm a
so haunting so how do i shadow know what
tell-tale heart you can you put it on my
face give oh yay whoa
oh come on a barian Omar you get my
stuff again crack oh I will kite ah no
kite him away you get your ex I'm
getting it I'm getting it I'm getting
okay got my ax huh
got this sorry here we go food who hit
him on oh yeah oh yeah
rapper aspect okay don't know what to do
oh okay
yeah yeah you can post whoa whoa oh okay
that's fine I'm low on health because I
just forgot okay me too
oh I need we need another telltale heart
can you up I've got uh uh how do I you
need grass it's made no less but you
don't have to be able to do it god oh
god no oh no there should be a Telemark
killed my tell-tale heart
yeah well oh you're good where is it
where is it where is it where is it I
don't see it
pinecone grass ICO there's no telltale
hard here it goes my grass would make
another one I had a lot of grass well
I'm low on health too I'll die oh good
you get how I had to read to read uh
yaps which if you cook them heal you
really well
all right good Abba you need to lead him
oh my gosh everything on fire oh how do
you do that can i light him on fire I
don't know man no I can't cook it you
just following me yeah I can't I can't
help you with that any more examples oh
never
yeah okay here we go I'm gonna spit hot
fire on these red caps I Spit on fire
get them get them get them get them yet
this is some okay you lit him
on fire
how on fire how'd you light him on fire
I don't know I'm just clicking the
out of them I'm gonna click sham to
we're gonna show it okay oh my god uh
we're ghost now why I don't what about
happen know how we can't mm can haunt
the chest can I
that's good haunting good job I'm gonna
Horace bar I guess good how did you
light everything on fire the one tree
like crazy I am stop clicking it no
matter what you do I don't think I was
done right we're never gonna be alive
again but we can't do it you know I
think oh good another tree monster where
there I I went my whole game without
seeing a single one of those damn tree
monsters and suddenly we've got two in
the same general area god oh that's what
we should have done like from the
beginning we should just win everything
on fire I mean that's what I was trying
to do until you were all top one going
on fire I'll try to kill it I didn't
know no how was I to know okay so oh
whoa look at this watch this I know I
know we can play back bad football oh
yeah I know
Wiki you hey a torch came out of it
when when we get to the next episode
we'll actually be in a place of good
fortune we'll set up a base we'll
actually have something to keep and
everything will be great right Bob
II yes yes definitely
okay good vote of confidence from Bob so
thanks again everybody for watching we
are so sorry for performing so poorly I
promise we'll be better and as always we
will see you in the next video oh my god
mark know that what are you staring so
intensely at my crotch I don't know no
get the camera wait oh my god what the
hell why no that happen was with
our luck that's horrible
good god and the tell-tale heart killed
you and then I got killed just from a
red cap by cooking it you said that
healed health yeah when I ate them oh oh
oh no I know what happened I was trying
to click on the campfire I was doing it
so spastically I must click an uncooked
one on myself oh damn it